tous
à une époque merveilleuse vivaient les
créatures les plus étonnantes qui ait
jamais foulé la terre comme moi non ça
c'est pas moi moi c'est là en bas
nous sommes des pachys rhino's or
peut-être pas aussi effrayant que les
gorgol mais bien plus coriace
ma mère ne couve des yeux et mon père
c'est le chef du troupeau et elle a ce
sont mes frères et soeurs
je sais qu'ils sont un peu lourd
pas facile d'être le plus petit dans ce
monde gigantesque mais finalement j'ai
grandi notre monde s'est transformé et
un jour ça a été mon tour d'être chaîne
pour entreprendre un voyage
à la recherche d'une nouvelle terre
plus belle aventure allait commencer